good morning believe nation today's
message is question yourself over to you
Roger Federer for me a very important of
the short-term goals then the long-term
is where do I want to be in six months
time because if you never set yourself
goals you can never question yourself
because you just move from one to the
next and you say it's gonna be okay and
the best thing I've done to be honest in
the last ten years I think it was
questioning myself in the best of times
when things are going great what more
can I do how much better can I become
how much harder can I train I think this
is a really important message for
entrepreneurs because oftentimes the
people around you can't push you to get
better I think this is why I go on and
on and on about the importance of
environment I look at myself and I look
at the businesses that I built and a lot
of the people around me look up to me
and think I want to be like governor I
want to do my own version of that and
that's awesome and that's really
humbling but who are the people around
me who are pushing me to want to do more
to look at what I've built to look at
Toronto that's awesome to look at my
YouTube channel to look at my website
and say Evan yeah that's good but you
know it could be way better and I think
you have to do that yourself and you
have to create an environment that
creates that for you to be your hardest
critic to surround yourself with ideas
and energy and creativity that forces
you to always want to try to get better
when you are at the top of your game to
have it not be enough right I want to
disrupt this school even more I want to
disrupt the YouTube world even more and
the way I do it is I surround myself
with the top 10 rules for success videos
the interesting videos you know I'm
reading Howard Schultz's book right now
I consume Walt Disney and Steve Jobs and
super successful entrepreneurs and I
realized that what I've done is nothing
there's like tiny nothing compared to
what others have done and that pushes me
to want to get better and so if you find
yourself in an environment where
you're comfortable where you don't have
that motivation from outside of people
we're telling you to get better then
create it for yourself because otherwise
you get bored you stagnate and you don't
realize your full potential as an
entrepreneur so the question today today
is how do you question yourself leave it
in the comments below I'll join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events Press